[Musique]
nous sommes en plein milieu du désert de
chihuahua
à
une heure de la frontière mexicaine
de nulle part surgit ce magasin prada
rien n'est à vendre c'est en fait une
oeuvre d'art qui annonce la
particularité de marfa
on compte ici pas moins de dix neuf
galeries d'art et d'exposition
pas mal pour une petite ville de 2000
âmes
c'est ici que s'est installée il ya
quinze ans l'artiste julie speed
a fait du shopping
elle expose et vend ses toiles un peu
partout aux états unis depuis mars à son
petit paradis
et
mar fall artistique vite aussi la nuit
comme ici dans les ténèbres en plein
milieu d'un champ
rob mazurek un musicien de chicago qui
joue un peu partout dans le monde a lui
aussi choisi la ville texane de marfa
[Musique]
musique
mais qu'est ce qui attire tous ces
artistes à marfa
tout a commencé il ya 50 ans ici sur
cette base militaire désaffectée dont on
ne peut pas vraiment vous montrer grand
chose
car toute image est soumise au droit
d'auteur par la fondation chine ati qui
gère l'héritage artistique de donald
judd un artiste minimaliste new yorkais
dont les créations sont exposées ici
ainsi à marfa on chuchote qu'une
personne sur quatre se définit comme
artiste
bon je vis dans une petite ville mais on
est quand même dans le désert
ça m'impressionne tellement parmi elles
la montréalaise magali guérin un gros
changement surtout pour quelqu'un qui
est toujours déménager dans les grandes
villes ces candidats mais
sachez qu'avant à chicago
artiste d'art abstrait c'est après une
résidence au sein de la fondation
sinatti qu'elle a décidé de s'établir
ici moi j'ai l'impression que c'est
nécessaire chaque artiste de venir ici
moins une fois à visiter maintenant on
n'a plus besoin
des grandes villes pour faire partie de
la conversation
l'idée que ce que la vie peut être un
petit peu plus
présente 5 dell
au niveau de l'environnement
morpho est elle donc une muse là dessus
ces résidences entente les pics une nuit
sans 2018 les couleurs de mes fans
sauront changer beaucoup
loin des tumultes des grandes villes
marfa continue d'être un aimant pour les
artistes
à coin de pays hors du temps où la
culture survie et rayonne
[Musique]